Nó này 1 mùi thằng chiến năm 2019,通 tiến từ công an thành phố Hanoi, đơn vị đã sự phát một chương vợp đăng tải hình an gm mặc cho phục công an nhân dân, có lội dùng sai sự thật.
Chứ đó, qua công tác nắm tình nghiền chia khong dành mà, phòng an nhưng màng và phòng trống tội phạm sự dụng công nghệ cao công an thành phố Hanoi,
gọi tất là phòng, phát hiện một tệ khoản phía s目 đăng tải bài viết có nội dùng.
Chứ nàn còn mỗi hình xa cài nữa thôi, cây miền an gmặc cho phục của lực lượng công an nhân dân.
Phòng đã sắp mình, làm việc với chủ tệ khoản chinh là hát VK, sinh năm 2019, chủ tệ sắp sơn Hanoi để làm só hình vi.
Sử dụng không ra mạng năng tải bài vi có nội dùng sai sự thật anh hưởng đến U.T.
Hình anh lực lượng công an nhân dân. Tại các quan công an, cây đã thường những hình vi đang tải của mình với một BIC CO-View,
câu lại, tăng U.T. lực tương tắc của bài viết.
Phòng đã giác quyết định sự phát bài phẩy năm triệu đồng bởi vì cây về hình vi, con cóp chia sẻ thông tin giả mọt.
Tăng tin giả giữa thật, xuyên tạc của không xuất phạc yーティng của cơ quan, tổ chức, giảy giữa những phẩm của càng nhân.